nos dicen arrastra el punto anaranjado
para graficar menos 2.5 2 luego
selecciona su ubicación en el plano
coordenada este es nuestro plano
coordenada aquí está el punto anaranjado
y más abajo tenemos las opciones de
ubicación si es el primer cuadrante
segundo cuadrante tercer cuadrante
cuarto cuadrante eje x o eje y veamos
primero la ubicación del punto las
coordenadas que nos dan son menos 2.5
esta es la coordenada que va en el eje x
vemos que es un valor negativo por lo
que va a ir del lado izquierdo de este
eje el valor es menos 2.5
aquí tenemos menos 2 aquí está menos 3 y
justo aquí está el menos 2.5 vamos a
arrastrar nuestro punto anaranjado hasta
aquí muy bien ya lo tenemos en la
coordenada x pero nos falta posicionarlo
en la coordenada y la coordenada ya es
un valor positivo y su valor es 2
va a estar en esta parte arriba del eje
y va a estar aquí a esta altura del 2
entonces tomamos nuestro punto
anaranjado desde donde está en equis y
lo subimos al valor que le corresponde
en 2 - 2 puntos 5,2 en qué cuadrante
está bueno vemos que este es el primer
cuadrante y aquí no está este es el
segundo cuadrante y justo aquí es donde
se ubica el punto así que vamos a
seleccionar el segundo cuadrante vamos a
bajar a las opciones
elegimos segundo cuadrante y vamos a
verificar nuestra respuesta comprueba tu
respuesta es correcta vamos a hacer un
par de problemas más
ahora nos dicen arrastra el punto
anaranjado para graficar menos 59 y
luego selecciona su ubicación en el
plano coordenada muy similar al
ejercicio anterior sólo que ahora
tenemos diferentes valores en x y en g
en x tenemos menos 5 va a estar a la
izquierda del eje de las equis y lo
vamos a posicionar justo aquí
ahora nos dicen que el valor en g es
menos 9 va a estar hacia abajo del eje y
y tenemos que posicionarlo en el -9
bajamos un poco más aquí está este es el
menos 9 bajamos nuestro punto anaranjado
sin perder la posición que tenía en x
pero colocándolo en la posición del 5,9
y vemos que se encuentra en el primer
cuadrante a quien está segundo cuadrante
aquí tampoco está ahora está en el
tercer cuadrante vamos a seleccionar
esta opción
tercer cuadrante y vamos a revisar
nuestra respuesta
comprueba tu respuesta
es correcta hagamos un problema más
arrastre el punto anaranjado para
graficar dos menos seis y luego
selecciona su ubicación en el plano
coordinado nuevamente tenemos aquí
nuestro punto anaranjado y la coordenada
en x es 2 vamos a mover los dos lugares
a la derecha ahí está y la coordenada
menos 6 en la posición menos 6 bajamos
nuestro puntito anaranjado hasta el -6
aquí está en la coordenada 2 - 6 y se
encuentra en el primer cuadrante no el
segundo cuadrante tampoco el tercer
cuadrante tampoco y en el cuarto
cuadrante si vamos a seleccionar el
cuarto cuadrante cuarto cuadrante aquí y
vamos a verificar la respuesta
comprobamos la respuesta
es correcta